Trascrizione: Eileen Castillo
Revisore: Michele Gianella
[Inglese] Se non noi, chi?
[Inglese] Se non ora, quando?
Questa domanda può essere applicata
a innumerevoli contesti.
Se pensiamo a persone
che recentemente sono scese in guerra,
per combattere per un ideale;
se pensiamo alla lotta
per la parità di genere
e per i diritti civili.
Se pensiamo, anche, a una relazione.
Questa domanda può essere applicata
a innumerevoli contesti.
Parliamo, per esempio,
del cambiamento climatico.
Prometto che non parlerò tutta la sera
del cambiamento climatico:
è un tema che conosciamo benissimo tutti,
sul quale ci bombardano
ormai quotidianamente.
Ma se ci fermiamo a riflettere,
chi di noi pensa di essere responsabile
del cambiamento climatico?
Chi di noi, invece, pensa
che le sue azioni
possano fare la differenza
per risolvere un problema così grande?
Quando faccio questa domanda,
ci sono due tipologie di persone,
che rispondono in modo
diametralmente opposto.
Da un lato, chi allarga le braccia e dice:
"Non è responsabilità mia, anzi:
sto vivendo l'errore di qualcun altro"
e pensa che debbano essere la politica,
le economie globali, i governi,
a cambiare le cose.
Dall'altra, invece,
una risposta diametralmente opposta,
di quelli che scendono in piazza
per manifestare per il clima,
si incatenano agli alberi,
comprano soltanto prodotti vegani.
Probabilmente voi vi sarete riconosciuti
in una di queste categorie.
Personalmente io mi colloco
esattamente nel mezzo,
oscillo costantemente fra questi due poli.
Voglio raccontarvi qualcosa di me
che sanno soltanto le persone
che si sorbiscono
quotidianamente le mie paranoie,
ovvero il fatto che fin da quando
ero piccola, adolescente,
mi sono sempre sentita in colpa
per essere nata in questa parte di mondo,
per essere nata
in una famiglia benestante,
per essere nata in salute.
Mi sono sempre fatta
una domanda molto banale, ovvero:
perché io sì?
Perché una bambina come me
che però è nata in Brasile,
e oggi vive in una favela,
perché lei no?
Questa è una domanda che forse qualcuno
di voi si sarà fatto nella vita.
Nel corso della mia breve esistenza
ho cercato una risposta,
ho letto, studiato, viaggiato
e mi sono arrovellata:
ma alla fine, non l'ho trovata.
Per cui a un certo punto ho capito
che l'unico modo che avevo,
per alleviare questo senso di colpa,
era cercare di fare qualcosa di utile,
qualcosa che facesse,
di questo privilegio che ho,
qualcosa di profittevole per gli altri.
Voi direte, questo che c'entra?
C'entra perché quattro anni fa,
insieme a due socie,
ho fondato una startup.
Per raccontarvi quello che fa
questa startup,
parto da un banalissimo grafico
che descrive l'economia
che tutti oggi conosciamo,
ovvero l'economia lineare.
Questo tipo di economia
si basa, banalmente,
sul principio per cui un prodotto
viene costruito, realizzato,
per poi essere trasportato, distribuito,
venduto, utilizzato e buttato.
Qualcuno avrà sentito parlare
di economia circolare;
qualcuno saprà anche applicarla
a un caso concreto.
Quello che posso dirvi è che
l'economia circolare si basa su 4 R:
Recupera, Riutilizza, Ripara e Ricicla.
Sono quattro R alla base di un modello -
rivoluzionario, se ci pensiamo -
che ha l'obiettivo
di valorizzare la materia,
di valorizzare le risorse della natura,
piuttosto che sfruttarle.
La nostra startup si basa
sulla quarta R, quella del riciclo.
Vi faccio degli esempi concreti.
Una startup in Sicilia
ha trovato il modo di riciclare
le fibre organiche delle arance,
cioè la parte bianca delle bucce d'arance,
per produrre delle fibre tessili
e generare capi d'abbigliamento.
Una startup piemontese ha trovato il modo
di riciclare le bucce dei chicchi di riso
per produrre pannelli
fonoassorbenti per l'edilizia.
Oppure, ancora, una startup del Lazio
ha trovato il modo di riciclare il PET,
cioè la plastica che comunemente usiamo
per produrre le bottigliette.
L'ha riciclata in filati sintetici
per produrre capi d'abbigliamento:
banalmente, costumi da bagno.
Questi sono alcuni esempi
di quello che è l'economia circolare:
in particolare il riciclo,
in questo contesto.
L'economia circolare
si basa sul concetto di rete.
Per mettere in pratica
questo concetto così astratto,
questo modello teorico,
abbiamo realizzato una "piattaforma
georeferenziata di simbiosi industriale".
Voi direte, ma che è?
Se vi dicessi "Un Tinder dei rifiuti"?
Non fate finta di non sapere
cosa sia Tinder, quindi -
(Risate)
un Tinder dei rifiuti,
una piattaforma che ha lo scopo
di mettere in contatto le imprese,
di generare match in modo tale
che il rifiuto di un'azienda
possa essere la risorsa di un'altra.
L'economia circolare si basa
sul concetto di rete.
Anche noi lo siamo.
Siamo una startup innovativa,
una società benefit,
che vuol dire che non abbiamo,
come obiettivo,
solo quello di fare profitto,
ma anche quello di apportare
un contributo positivo
verso la comunità,
verso l'ambiente in cui operiamo.
Oggi siamo un team di 25 persone,
siamo in media under 30.
Realizzare questa startup,
questa piattaforma, non è stato facile:
anzi, è stata probabilmente
l'impresa più difficile
in cui mi sia mai cimentata.
Non sarei mai stata in grado
di farlo da sola.
Però ho creduto in un'idea,
e ho avuto la fortuna
di incontrare persone
che ci hanno creduto quanto me,
con le quali ho potuto
portare avanti questo progetto.
Oggi abbiamo 52 aziende clienti,
sul territorio nazionale.
Qualcuno dirà: "È un bel traguardo".
Altri diranno: "È un po' scarso".
Sono 52 imprese,
52 progetti che abbiamo attivato.
Se vi dicessi che,
attivando questi progetti,
abbiamo coinvolto più di 1000 aziende
in Italia e in Europa?
Pensereste che è una piccola grande rete.
Infatti è così.
Perché è la prova
che il cambiamento di uno,
il cambiamento del singolo,
possa attivare una collettività,
possa generare un cambiamento
su larga scala.
Questa è l'economia circolare.
Questa è la rete.
Ma perché succede?
Perché le aziende, oggi,
hanno necessità di qualificare
i loro fornitori,
di misurare la sostenibilità
della filiera produttiva.
E ancora, perche?
Perché siamo noi consumatori, a chiederlo.
E ancora, il cambiamento del singolo.
Noi rivestiamo il ruolo
di coloro che si attivano
per aiutare gli altri a credere
di poter essere artefici del cambiamento,
nel loro micro contesto.
Così che da quel piccolo cambiamento
si possa generare una reazione a catena,
estesa a un contesto molto più ampio.
Se non noi, chi?
Se non ora, quando?
Questa domanda può essere applicata
a innumerevoli contesti.
E se qualcuno, tra di voi,
oscilla come me fra quei due famosi poli,
io avrei voluto che qualcuno mi dicesse:
"Non puoi cambiare il mondo,
ma quello che fai ha un impatto,
micro o macro che sia."
Perché alla fine,
se non siamo noi a credere
di poter cambiare qualcosa,
chi dovrebbe farlo al posto nostro?
Grazie.
(Applausi)